[Music]
welcome to comic-con
welcome to our Collider suite whatever
the hell we're calling this thing I'm
the collider tent there we go the
outdoor adventure so I want to start by
saying I watch your show I've really
enjoyed this season like a lot I'm
looking forward to seeing the finale
which is I believe two nights from
midseason finale sorry my bad
midseason finale so what what's it been
like like just I have a million things
to talk about but let's jump into Comic
Con and being here I think for a second
ago we were just talking about hitting
the stage you guys were in Hall H today
7000 people do you get nervous yeah I
mean well we were saying like this is my
fifth year and I never I didn't think I
was like going onstage I was like I'm
not nervous like I haven't even thought
about this for a second just because
it's I'm just kind of used to it now the
first year I was just terrified but the
fifth year this year I was like I'm
chill then the moment I sat down the
first question was asked of me I
suddenly got that pang of adrenaline
that like oh oh I'm suddenly in front of
7,000 people I'm like okay I got
actually he focused and I got up and
then I was fine but yeah I guess it
still hits you it does I suddenly
remembered why they do question prep
because he asked me a question and when
they had said to me in the panel prep
that they're gonna ask you this question
I was like sorry I got it then he asked
me my mind just went blank and I said
something I'd said like a million times
was that wasn't even answering his
question it was like if I just keep
saying this I'll get there in the end
and I didn't I kind of did the same
thing I was like what did I say what did
I say what did I say in that [ __ ] that
prep interview Lennie backstage I was
looking at he's gives are you okay I was
like yeah this is my first time here at
comic-con and these guys are it's so
lovely to you know prep me and tell me
that you're gonna be in this massive
room and nothing quite prepares for you
prepares you for it when you're out
there with the adrenaline in the
atmosphere and the energy Lennie just
said to me who's not you're only gonna
be out there in front of 7,000 people
because what you're worried about and
I'm like like I'm like thanks thanks
thanks but many
good yeah you did really good I cannot
talk in front of 7,000 people I just
can't do it okay I could act but I can't
talk like even there like how was it
coming down here and coming to the other
show I was like breakfast tacos er that
was a good line there Tommy well the
thing I think the thing that a lot of
people don't realize is and I was
thinking about it you can be perfect
ninety nine point six percent of the
time and all you need is just one
screw-up and that's the gift that will
just live in the internet forever so no
pressure so I want to jump into a few
what I call fun questions right off the
bat which is first thing which if you
could crossover with another show on TV
right now
that would enter your world or you could
enter theirs either or what's the show
you would love to join with on right now
who could actually be a show from the
past as well okay Game of Thrones
I said Game of Thrones show from the
past sure The Sopranos I can't even
imagine
Tony Soprano be good though your face
off quite like to cross over into the
wire with my stick with you stick your
stick man no you can just stop right
there thank you hi there shows I would
have crossed over with but they would
not suit my character going over there
but like I would want to cross over with
like Mad Men but that would make no
sense at all very weird women all like
Breaking Bad would be good to listen
there's a lot of what if comic books
where at Comic Con so there's I like to
pose to pose the question of what if you
know what I mean but we can move past
this who ruins the most takes and why
you know what we are all really on top
of it because we don't have enough time
like the the rate we shoot at is just
like go go go so the only times we do is
like when it's just once every now and
then and someone gets the giggles and
then you just can't stop but it's very
it's kind of rare I think well the only
person
I know that his route will mean moe like
Moe like once she starts laughing yeah
it's impossible it's over mo Collins
like its I mean she like loses herself
it's pretty incredible who always gets
it on the first take right here it's not
actually true no it is so let's say it's
the truth when I first joined the show
and having to do an American accent and
I had no idea Alicia was not I I never
thought her American accent so brilliant
and I I was sliding remember when I had
my first scenes with these two lovelies
and I had a lot of scientific jargon you
remember with different versions and I
was like with the hazmat suit and then
falling out it was just like wow I could
even focus and I was just brain farting
all over I'm so sorry
you did well so it's always first take
no it's not it's really it's really nice
[Laughter]
you want them taking it home I'm gonna
phone my wife and say guess what they
said about me
the thing that you mentioned is that on
you have I think what eight days to
shoot your show so you have eight days
you to shoot an episode sorry and but
that's with the amount because you guys
have a lot of action every episode you
have a lot of meaty dialogue scenes and
I'm just curious how do you typically
like to learn your lines
in that kind of schedule where you might
have one day you have like pages of
dialogue and it might change the night
before you prioritize the day I mean I
do I think it's kind of similar for all
of us you prioritize like big chunky
dialogue with like as soon as possible
even if it's like two days away you kind
of get that done and at least it's like
then in your head and even if it does
change at least the the basic structure
is there and then as for everything else
I mean we've been doing this so long
that like action anything stunts related
even when you on the day you kind of
we've got such a wonderful stunt team
and and we've been doing it enough that
it's almost like second nature that you
can kind of jump in pretty much pick it
up pretty quickly
and then go straight into it so yeah
it's but it's a balance and and it's
definitely prioritizing the hard stuff
so you're not surprised when you're when
you're there with it especially when we
have stunts and all that like for me I
thought I was a good multitasker until I
joined this show and I was quickly
humbled and realized I'm not really good
at multitasking
it's a bit a skill set that you you we
really do like it's a stamina it's like
you learn how to build up these like I
don't know yeah yeah and I think it's
something whereby you can say it to new
people coming on I mean I think I said
it to Karen I said this is a really
physical show this to it show is gonna
really take it out of you and you can
say it but it's not until you feel it
there and it was a few months down the
road and Karen said wow you're not
kidding oh yeah this is this takes it
out of you and you're right it's every
every new actor we have on the show it
is a bit of a shock just because of the
the amount of that we shoot and the
intensity of what it is the scale that
it is and it is fast so it is a bit of a
shock but it is a muscle that you really
do learn to flex but I want to get
specific if you don't mind I'm
fascinated by what do you actually do
you're in your apartment or house you're
in your trailer what do you do to learn
those lines are you can you can you
share how you each do it I've read the
script I've read the script I read the
script I read the script I read the
script are you saying it out loud or
sometimes I'm saying it out loud
sometimes I'm not for me it's you know I
have a little bit of a photographic
memory so so so learning so my wife what
you said now that learning lines aren't
is very difficult for me but so I read
the script so I just want to know the
thoughts and if you and mostly if you
know the thoughts you never forget the
lines
on the weekends like if usually on the
weekend especially because there's so
much technical jargon for grace and if
we're doing stunts especially I don't
want to think about Minot and then on
top of that an American accent mmm and
trying to be as authentic as possible so
I have to look at I look at the schedule
the shooting schedule and on the
weekends I'll just break it down and
I'll memorize a whole week's worth
and I'll some will be more engraved in
my head obviously for the ones on Monday
Tuesday and then going forward so that I
don't even have to think about it when I
get to it but I'll say the lines out
loud I'll like feel them out and then
I'll go and do something and then I'll
come back again and just about just
saying it not over practicing either
because you want things to be quite
organic and spontaneous in the moment
too so it's much harder learning lines
by yourself I find like the moment I
have anyone that I can just like bounce
it off then it's like I've got it in two
minutes it's always when you're by
yourself which is most common that's
most of the time but I like I'll
highlight and then I pick my color of
highlighter I do and i write my little
notes and then yeah I mean I'm like
sitting my apartment I actually pace in
my apartment and just like state lines
over and over and over until they're
kind of there and then yeah feels good
there's a lot of different techniques
and what Lenny said is once you find the
meaning it's the lines are there but
I'll also pace if it's like a big
monologue you know I'm in my backyard
just saying it over and over by rote no
intonation or anything so it's I so you
keep it fresh you don't you don't get in
a pattern or a rhythm and then the other
thing is sometimes I'll put like I'll
read the scene in my phone recorder but
not put my lines in it so it's just I
can you know you can get the other
person's lines okay we'd like hearing
your own voice reading the other lines
back like does that yeah throws me off
I think whatever you what whatever you
do and you don't want to overdo it
because you want to allow the
possibility that when you get on set
everything could change the for now the
mid-season finale is Sunday night and
then so I I know it obviously we have to
spoilers which is one of the reasons why
we're talking about other things but
what can you tease people about the
finale in the next part of the season if
anything it's gonna be a lot of running
so you guys can join Tom Cruise in his
next adventure Alicia said it the other
day she said this this finale this
mid-season finale felt like a finale
when we were filming it it was kind it's
it was kind of full-on and I think the
back half of the season for my character
at least one of the things that I'm kind
of most impressed about the writers and
our kind of creators on this particular
show is that they keep on coming up with
new challenges for the characters and
new walker kills and you know new
different ways of getting rid of you
know the walkers and people and and
they've managed to come up with a really
big challenge for Morgan in the second
half of the season he he's got he's got
to face something and I think he never
thought he was going to have to face and
I think it's gonna rock him to his core
it's probably on one level the most
frightening thing he's had to face since
the apocalypse began so I'm looking
forward to the fancy in that and that's
the answer I'm meant to give that's what
it was that's the answer I'm meant to
give them the I'll be the first question
in Hall H that was the answer I think
friends are just gonna have to brace
themselves everyone it's very big
like Alicia said it felt like a finale
it's very big it's very epic we're
dealing with very heightened
circumstances with those irradiated
irradiated walkers I think for for grace
it's very much it's always about the
bloody generator and I I'm excited for
grace for the second half she's being
thrown more out of her comfort zone
because she's been so isolated she
chooses to be isolated in dealing with
with her traumas and and the choices
that she's made in the past and as she's
getting to know Morgan and hopefully the
rest of the group you know she's she's
got to kind of open up a little bit more
and
I was really good for that isn't she
when she interviews all you guys and
yeah yeah so let's see hopefully she'll
open up a bit more adventure excitement
yeah it's also a circumstance that sort
of can either pin you against somebody
or bring you together and I think we're
all trying to finagle our way around
that like the group and sort of the
relationships and what we're gonna do I
mean it's big it's really big and I will
say for Alicia I think it's a quest for
a happiness a little bit sure I know I
got there I'm just gonna say first of
all Congrats on getting another season
thank you very much it's not I think a
lot of people I say this all the time
it's not just the actors that are now
happy there's a ton hundreds of people
on the crew and all these other people
that just got more work so it's awesome
for everyone we have such a wonderful
hard-working crew and constant creatives
so which is happy for everyone I'm just
glad thank you they're willing to come
back and do what they do for us because
they don't have to what they do because
I know where most of them live I get to
I get to call you Momo fur and I know
you really done yes we do
no I just think a lot of people it's not
just a you know there's so many people
when a renewal happens it affects so
many people's lives you know and anyway
listen Congrats super thank you so much
for coming in and hopefully I see you
again next year
thank you